des moyens supplémentaires pour cette
nouvelle année scolaire 550 postes ont
été créés dans le premier degré de
l'académie de versailles mais 110
emplois dans les lycées et collèges
nous avons accueilli les jeunes
professeurs mais il peut manquer
évidemment ici et là il manquera
certainement ici et là je serai rassurée
là encore les familles ou les équipes
dans les collèges et des lycées tout le
rectorat est mobilisé dans le second
degré 65 mille cinq cents élèves sont
rentrés dans les 130 collège des
yvelines mise en oeuvre à la rentrée
2016 la réforme des collèges est
assouplie objectif donner plus
d'initiatives aux établissements des
projets pédagogiques qui vont s'opérer
au 6e en réseau notamment en éducation
prioritaire puisque nous sommes à
versailles je pensais au secteur de
manteaux secteur de trappes comment
l'ensemble des collèges ont un projet
projet linguistique projet culturel avec
leurs élèves pour le premier degré plus
de 149 mille élèves sont accueillis dans
les neuf cent soixante douze écoles
maternelles et primaires yvelinoise
principal changement en élémentaire le
retour à la semaine des quatre jours
près de 57 % des communes du département
ont décidé de revenir sur la réforme des
rythmes scolaires
à noter aussi 5 réseau d'éducation
prioritaire renforcée des yvelines vont
bénéficier du dispositif de classe de cp
à 12 élèves